today I'll show you how to deploy nginx  plus in Google Cloud flasher nginx plus  is a complete application delivery  platform combining load balancing  content caching web server security  controls and monitoring in cloud  launcher type nginx in a search bar and  select engine x+ from the results click  Launch on Google cloud platform select  the project where you want to deploy  nginx Plus and click continue next  configure the name and other parameters  for a new instance click deploy and  instance with the latest version of  Android X + whale deploy to learn more  about nginx configuration and activate  support click getting started and go to  nginx support engineer to get started  with spandex + + Club launcher click on  the link in the comments thanks for  watching